wir sind schon beim nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
27 novelle des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
kurz bafög
1971 wurde es von der sozial-liberalen
koalition eingeführt jetzt schon die 27
novelle es gibt einen gesetzentwurf
dazu aus der bundesregierung und
ebenfalls in dieser debatte mit
diskutiert wer einen antrag der
linksfraktion mit dem titel bafög
existenzsichernd und krisenfest
gestalten mit der bafög reform soll der
kreis der anspruchsberechtigten
erweitert werden die gezahlten sätze
sollen erhöht werden vorgesehen ist ein
anstieg des sogenannten grundbedarfs
satzes von
427 auf
449 euro im monat das ist nicht ganz
viel
angesichts der aktuellen
preissteigerungen die wir haben und die
hier eben auch schon in der debatte
diskutiert worden sind aber die wohn
pauschale für studierende die nicht bei
den eltern wohnen soll von 325 auf 360
euro steigen von spd bündnis 90 die
grünen fdp die übrigen fraktionen haben
dagegen gestimmt enthaltungen gab es
keine
ich rufe jetzt auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 9a und so dass ich
jetzt gesehen haben dass hier eine kurze
abstimmung noch mal stattgefunden hat
das war die frage was er mit dem antrag
der unionsfraktion zum thema
preissteigerungen passieren soll er
heute schon abgestimmt werden oder im
ausschuss in zuständigen leiter
diskutiert so ist es dann auch bekommen
wird also noch weiter beraten werden und
jetzt sehen sie wieder große rotation
hier im plenum sie sehen auch schon die
bundesbildungsministerin bettina stark
watzinger die natürlich eine gewichtige
rolle spielt bei der reform des bafögs
ganz einfach weil sie dafür zuständig
ist als ministerin gibt es noch wie
gesagt noch ein bisschen
personalrotation weil die
fachpolitikerin
wechseln und dann wird es hier in kürze
auch losgehen können es gibt noch den 1
und anderen schwarz neben den rein wie
wir hier sehen
und eine geduldige bundestags
vizepräsidentin katrin göring eckardt
die jetzt allerdings ein bisschen
dampf macht
nicht folgen wollen den saal zu
verlassen
da ist noch
debatte
so
ich eröffne die aussprache und gebe das
wort der bundesministerin bettina stark
watzinger die heute ihren geburtstag
feiert zu der ich im namen hause ist und
alle anderen funktionierte
ganz herzlichen dank das schönste
geburtstagsgeschenk ist dass ich heute
einen gesetzentwurf einbringen sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen viele junge
menschen haben dieser regierung bei der
letzten bundestagswahl ihre stimme ihr
vertrauen gegeben deswegen war der
auftrag klar das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung ist dass chance
ministerium und deswegen stand die
reform des bafögs ganz oben auf unserer
prioritätenliste
das bafög
ist seit künftig jahr und das zentrale
instrument damit auch diejenigen ihren
bildungsweg frei und selbstbestimmt
wählen können deren eltern ihnen nicht
finanzieren können bafög bedeutet
freiheit nicht der geldbeutel der eltern
entscheidet sondern der junge mensch
selbst
bedeutet chancengerechtigkeit vor kurzem
hat der berliner architekt francis kéré
den renommierten pritzker preis gewonnen
er stammt aus burkina faso und konnte in
deutschland studieren und was sagt er in
einem interview
bildung ist alles und ohne bafög wäre
ich heute kein tritt der preisträger
millionen haben vom bafög profitiert
unser land hat davon profitiert jeder
euro für bildung ist doppelt investiert
aber werte ist aus nun gibt es nicht die
zeiten ändern sich nach steuern tut not
lange ist das beim bafög versäumt worden
daher die dringlichkeit jetzt wir haben
im koalitionsvertrag eine strukturelle
reform vereinbart jetzt gehen wir den
ersten wichtigen schritt damit möglichst
schnell möglichst viele vom fortschritt
profitieren können 2,3 milliarden euro
sind für die reform in dieser
legislaturperiode
eingeplant
2,3 milliarden für mehr freiheit für
mehr chancengerechtigkeit das heißt wir
nehmen die nächste stufe im
aufstiegsversprechen denn niemand kann
sich aussuchen woher er kommt aber er
soll sich aussuchen können wohin er geht
und steht
vorgesehen wir werden beides erhöhen die
fördersätze und die zahl derer die sie
in anspruch nehmen wir heben die
freibeträge beim einkommen der eltern um
satte 20 prozent an das erhöht die
reichweite des bafög deutlich
damit erreichen wir nämlich auch viele
bei denen das studium auf der kippe
stand weil die eltern zwar nicht
schlecht verdient aber es immer noch
nicht reicht um diese erhebliche
belastung zu stemmen und auch der
förderhöchstbetrag wird deutlich steigen
nämlich um 8 prozent auf
931 euro wir wollen die bedarfssätze
anheben den kinderbetreuungszuschlag
aber vor allen dingen auch den wohn
zuschlag denn die mieten steigen und die
energiekosten steigen deshalb auch noch
mal außerhalb des bafög der
heizkostenzuschuss den wir den
studierenden gewähren
und wir wollen denjenigen diejenigen
unterstützen die später im leben sich
entscheiden ein studium oder eine
ausbildung
aufzunehmen und deswegen haben wir die
altersgrenze an auf 45 jahre klar ist
das bafög muss sich dem leben anpassen
nicht umgekehrt
dazu gehören auch einfache verfahren ich
habe mich selbst einmal an ein
bafög-antrag gesetzt und testweise
ausgefüllt das ging ganz gut aber dann
kommt der punkt an dem man ihn
übermitteln möchte hier müssen die
studierenden entweder ausdrucken und per
post schicken oder sie haben ein ausweis
mit einer id was man in der regel nicht
hat digitalisierung gut gemeint aber
schlecht gemacht wo sind wir eigentlich
mit der reform klappt das beantragen
dann endlich komplett digital wir leben
im digitalen zeitalter
nach ein letztes ist noch wichtig nach
20 jahren soll es endlich leichter
werden die restschulden erlassen zu
bekommen ohne komplizierte
antragsverfahren das bafög kommt in
unserer zeit an flexibler attraktiver
und moderner
bereits ab herbst sollen die änderungen
wirken das ist ein anfang ein erster
aber er kommt weiterhin planen wir
erstens das nothilfe instrument beim
bafög und für künftige krisen besser
gewappnet zu sein
zweitens die studien starthilfe wir
wollen junge menschen unterstützen wenn
sie aus familien kommen den geld für
umzug immatrikulation oder it
ausstattung fehlt und drittens mehr
flexibilität bei der höchster des bafög
bezug sum beim fachrichtungswechsel sind
geplant natürlich auch die
elternunabhängige komponente eines
möchte ich noch sagen es ist richtig ab
juni sollen auch geflüchtete studierende
aus der ukraine bafög bekommen für uns
ist klar wir schaffen gute
startbedingungen für alle jungen
menschen in unserem land
und wird sagen einige alles viel zu
wenig vor allen zu wenig geld ja das ist
wohlfeil und ja jeder euro in der tasche
ist natürlich auch immer gut aber wir
brauchen die richtige balance zwischen
denen die zahlen und denen die etwas
bekommen und diese müssen wir immer
wieder neu austarieren doch der nutzen
der bildung für alle liegt auf der hand
und das und ich auf die debatte
dankeschön
bettina stark watzinger an ihrem
geburtstag mit ihren anmerkungen zur
geplanten novelle des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
ist die inzwischen 27 novelle die da
geplant erst und die erste gegen rhede
dazu kommt aus der unionsfraktion und
von kathrin staffler
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
zu klein zu wenig zu kurz gegriffen
reförmchen alles bezeichnungen die wir
im zusammenhang mit der novelle gehört
haben und gelesen haben die heute hier
vorlegt und dabei haben sie dieses
vorhaben doch so unglaublich groß
angekündigt sie wollten so schnell wie
möglich auf den weg bringen und ich muss
leider sagen der effekt ist verpufft
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen schnell
zu arbeiten nur damit man etwas
vorweisen kann bedeutet nicht immer das
was auch gut wird wobei an der stelle
muss man sagen über geschwindigkeit kann
man ja auch streiten angesichts der
tatsache dass es der erste gesetzentwurf
in dem bereich ist und inzwischen schon
fast ein halbes jahr im amt vergangen
ist es wäre an der stelle trotzdem
vernünftig gewesen man hätte noch einmal
innegehalten sie hätten hinterfragt ob
das was sie da geplant haben auch
wirklich sinn macht oder ob man
vielleicht doch noch mal drüber
nachdenken muss
aber lassen sie mich von vorne beginnen
und bevor sie jetzt alle hier
unglaublich schreien und sich angefasst
fühlen ich kann aber mit dem positiven
dingen anfangen die ministerin hat heute
geburtstag und ich glaube da darf man
auch mal das ein oder andere positiven
vorbringen in bildung ist der wichtigste
rohstoff für eine gute zukunft des bafög
ist ein essenzieller teil davon es trägt
auch maßgeblich dazu bei dass wir mehr
bildungsgerechtigkeit hier in unserem
land haben und dafür daher ist es
richtig und ich finde es auch gut dass
sie die reform des bafögs jetzt
frühzeitig auch auf die agenda gesetzt
haben und dieses thema als erstes
anpacken und angesichts der
herausforderungen der letzten beiden
jahre und natürlich auch der aktuellen
situation in der mir und die studenten
jetzt auch befinden ist es von größter
wichtigkeit dass wir den studenten leben
unter die arme greife und dass wir sie
so gut wie es irgendwie geht auch
unterstützen aber wenn man jetzt die
entlastungen genauer ansieht die hier in
letzter zeit auch beschlossen worden
sind dann stehen eben genau die
studenten ehrlicherweise nicht besonders
weit oben auf ihrer prioritätenliste
wenn sie da überhaupt zu finden sind und
es ist eben leider jetzt auch in dieser
baufeld novelle
nicht unbedingt positiv zu bemerken wenn
man die novelle ließ lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen dann kommt einem
bestenfalls noch eine sache in den sinn
nämlich kontinuität ich habe die zahlen
der letzten novelle gegenübergestellt
und was soll ich sagen mit der novelle
setzen sie jetzt im endeffekt nichts
anderes wort wie das was wir in der
letzten legislaturperiode bereits
begonnen haben
sie haben es gerade geschrieben die
digitale antragstellung soll weiter
ausgebaut werden genauso wie die aller
möglichkeiten hinsichtlich von
darlehensforderungen mit der
sechsundzwanzigster bafög-novelle also
die die wir luft gemacht haben 2009 10
waren wir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
mutiger als sie wir haben zum beispiel
den wohn zuschlag für auswärts wohnen
der um 30 prozent angehoben zu jedem
märz um zehn prozent noch einmal an auch
haben wir den kinderbetreuungszuschlag
angehoben um 13 prozent die altersgrenze
auf 14 jahre heraufgesetzt
also 13 prozent in der letzten novelle
sie erhöhen ja zum 5 prozent wenn bei
der derzeitigen inflation
man überhaupt noch von einer höhe
erhöhung sprechen kann an der stelle ich
wage es zu bezweifeln ehrlicherweise
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist
soll er an der stelle auch keinen
überbietungswettbewerb sein und werden
dafür ist das bafög zu wichtig auch wenn
sie da jetzt drüber lachen mögen für uns
ist es wichtig aber vielleicht hat man
mal in aller ruhe hinsetzen sollen und
überlegen warum das bafög überhaupt
immer weniger menschen erreicht und
welche erhöhung und welche erhöhung der
beitragssätze überhaupt angemessen
gewesen werden und sie argumentieren
natürlich jetzt dass sie die aktuelle
lage mit voraussehen haben können
gekauft aber vielleicht hat man besser
wenn die letzte novelle immer nur irgend
wollen und sehen wo wirklich der schuh
drückt denn dann hätten sie
wahrscheinlich gemerkt dass viele
studierende auch deswegen kein bafög
beantragen weil sie heute antrags
berechtigte personen teilweise am
antrags prozedere schon scheitern und
man hat auch mehr an dieser
stellschraube
darsteller wie der antragstellung drehen
können ich möchte sogar sagen man hätte
an dieser stellschraube drehen müssen
und übrigens liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die von mir am anfang der rede
erwähnten bezeichnungen für die novelle
sie erinnern sich vielleicht sie haben
ja alle ganz große aufgeschrieben zu
klein zu wenig zu kurz gegriffen
reförmchen
sie haben auf geschehen weil sie gedacht
haben das ist das was mir über ihr
gesetz gesagt haben mitnichten sie kamen
nämlich nicht von uns das waren
überwiegend aus den reihen ihrer eigenen
jugendverbände ein bündnis von
studierenden verbänden darunter jusos
grüne jugend fzs juso hochschulgruppen
campusgrün gw studis ig metall jugend
die alle es sind nämlich der meinung
dass die anpassung der regelsätze sich
immer noch nicht an dem wirklichen
bedarf von studierenden anpassen würden
ich glaube das sollte ihnen durchaus zu
denken geben wenn aus den eigenen reihen
so massiv die kritik aufkommt
so und jetzt möchte ich am schluss aber
noch einmal zum zum positiven oder oder
im positiven
an der stelle werden nämlich am ende
sind wir uns doch eigentlich alle einig
das bafög darf nicht stehenbleiben wir
brauchen eine reform wir müssen
gemeinsam daran arbeiten dass das bafög
auch weiterhin dem bedürfnis der
studierenden gerecht wird statt hier
solche halbgaren novellen vorzulegen und
einsatz zum schluss liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich hätte noch eine bitte
an sie vergessen sie bitte bei all ihrem
vorhaben die studenten net weder die die
bafög beziehen noch die die kein bafög
beziehen die haben alle enorm gelitten
in den letzten beiden jahren und
trotzdem viel geleistet und auch in der
aktuellen situation brauchen sie unsere
unterstützung und wir dürfen ihnen diese
unterstützung bitte nicht verwehren
besten bank
und der bundestag diskutiert über die 27
bafög novelle und sie diskutiert über
ein tag der linken mit dem titel bafög
existenzsichernd und krisenfest
gestalten und in dieser debatte ist
jetzt lena seidel am pult aus der spd
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
ministerin stark watzinger sehr geehrte
kolleginnen kollegen zeig mir deine
eltern und ich sag dir welchen abschluss
zu machen
das war die realität vor 100 jahren vor
70 jahren und es ist sie leider gottes
auch immer noch heute im jahr 2022 wir
sind uns hier alle einig und wir sagen
dass auch immer wieder bildung ist der
schlüssel zur gesellschaftlichen
teilhabe zum sozialen aufstieg und zur
selbstverwirklichung und dennoch zieht
sich bildungs ungleichheit in unserem
land durch alle bildungsgänge vom
kindergarten über den berufsabschluss
bis hin zur promotion das elternhaus
öffnet türen oder es verschließt sie
und lassen sie mich dazu eine kleine
bestandsaufnahme machen werden fast 80
prozent aller kinder aus
akademikerhaushalten ein studium
beginnen schafft es nicht einmal jedes
dritte kind aus nicht akademischen
elternhäusern
verfügen die eltern über gar keinen
berufsabschluss ist der weg zur
hochschule fast gänzlich verschlossen
denn diese über hürde zu überwinden
schafft dann nur noch jedes fünfzigste
kind und natürlich muss nicht jeder an
die hochschule aber diese beispiele
zeigen doch wie sehr der bildungsweg vom
elternhaus abhängt in keinem anderen
land in der europäischen union ist der
zugang zu bildung so exklusiv und
selektiv wie bei uns liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
dabei war das auch schon mal anders als
das bafög vor 50 jahren vor über 50
jahren durch die sozial liberale
koalition unter bundeskanzler willy
brandt eingeführt wurde sollte ein
paradigmenwechsel vollzogen werden die
idee dahinter bildungsgerechtigkeit
entreißt man nur durch eine breite
ausbildungsförderung der zugang zu
bildung sollte unabhängig werden vom
elternhaus und eben nicht nur ein
privileg der oberschicht und das budget
wurde schnell zum erfolg durch die
finanzielle unterstützung wurde der
zugang zur schule und berufsausbildung
deutlich erleichtert direkt nach seiner
einführung erhielt fast die hälfte aller
studierenden eine staatliche
vollförderung dadurch öffneten sich die
hochschulen für die breite der
gesellschaft und das möchte ich
insbesondere aufgrund der rede von frau
-staffel hier auch noch mal ganz ehrlich
sagen diese ganzen errungenschaften die
ich hier gerade aufgeführt habe die
wohnen beginnend mit der kohl-regierung
wieder umgekehrt jetzt ging es nicht
darum die förderberechtigten
einzugrenzen die staatlichen zuschüsse
zu reduzieren würden wurden hochgezogen
bildung wieder exklusiver die zahl der
darf durch bafög geförderten jungen
menschen haben deutlich ab das
verschuldungsrisiko dagegen zu gespart
wurde am gleichberechtigten
bildungszugang nachdem mutter zugang zu
bildung steht immer mehr nur den offen
die es sich leisten kann das ist die
realität und frau stadler ich freue mich
sehr dass die union da offensichtlich
eine umkehr jetzt mit gedacht hat und
dass wir gemeint ulrich studierenden und
für das café kämpfen
weil die folgen dieser
bildungsungerechtigkeit sind immens für
jeden einzelnen aber auch für die
gesellschaft sie gefährdet nicht nur
unser gesellschaftliches klima sie
verschließt denner über generationen
hinweg türen und sie grenzt weite teile
der bevölkerung aus denn fehlende
bildungschancen bringen soziale
explosion und ein unweigerlich das
armutsrisiko mit sich zu schrecken die
freie berufswahl und den weiteren werde
eingang diesen teufelskreis müssen wir
nachhaltig durchbrechen dann ist das
geschafft dann haben nicht nur die
nachfolge generation wieder die
möglichkeit zur teilhabe und zum
sozialen aufstieg sondern wir als
gesamtgesellschaft wir schaffen einen
nährboden der talente wieder erkennt und
fördert um jungen menschen die chance
gibt eurem weg zu gehen darin geht und
ich profitiert nicht nur die einzelnen
schülern oder studenten oder
auszubildende dadurch profitieren wir
alle wir als gesamtgesellschaft wir als
wissenschaftsstandort deutschland das
muss unser ziel sein
und diese kolleginnen kollegen mit der
heutigen novelle gehen wir nicht nur ein
kleines reform stückchen sondern wir
beschließen heute den beginn einer
trendwende
explizit in beginnen denn nach vielen
jahren große reform anstrengungen drehen
wir die abwärtsspirale im berg wieder um
die eröffnen des bafög für mehr junge
menschen wir heben die freibeträge um
20% an die altersgrenze auf 45 jahre wir
erhöhen die bedarfssätze den wohnkosten
zuschlag den kinderbetreuungszuschlag
und mehr erleichtern die digitale
antragstellung des alles änderungen die
dringend notwendigen machen wir sie
jetzt und nicht erst in zwei jahren
sondern wir brauchen sie jetzt umso
treten im wintersemester dann auch ein
aber und das hat die frau ministerin
auch gerade schon gesagt wir wollen uns
darauf nicht aus weil es gibt dringenden
auch strukturellen reform bedarf den
haben wir fest im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbarte setzen wir unten und für uns
als spd stehen hier insbesondere die
verlängerung der voerder höchstdauer und
die absenkung des darlehen anteils im
vordergrund sie sehen meine damen und
herren es gabe hat absolute priorität
für die ampel koalition aber bevor wir
jetzt an diese große reform machen haben
wir heute erst mal ein grund zu feiern
nicht nur weil sie vom ministerin heute
geburtstag haben an dieser stelle
herzlichen glückwunsch auch noch von mir
sondern vor allem weil wir mit dieser
novelle den grundstein für eine echte
trendwende im bafög leben bildung ist
der schlüssel zur gesellschaftlichen
teilhabe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie ihn uns vervielfältigen
china sein ziel war das was der spd
fraktion in der debatte zum
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetz
bzw dessen inzwischen 27 novelle die
hier an steht und gerade diskutiert wird
und da ist der nächste redner götz
flamingos der afg fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin sehr geehrte
damen und herren also lassen sie mich zu
beginn doch noch mal ein wort sagen zu
meiner vorrednerin sehr geehrte frau dr
seite also das war ein wahres horror
bild was sie dann gezeichnet haben
welches land ist denn das wo man so
diskriminiert wird wo arbeiterkinder
kein abitur bekommen wo sie vom studium
abgehalten werden also ich kann nur
sagen vor ihnen steht jemand dessen
eltern kein abitur hatten und einfach
ihr normalen beruf nachgegangen sind und
ich bin 1968 geboren ich bin in bayern
zur grundschule gegangen ich habe dort
mein abitur gemacht ich habe später
studiert und das ging alles in diesem
landes ging wunderbar und viele machen
das und machen das tagtäglich die zahl
der abiturienten und der studenten
steigt unaufhörlich also hören sie doch
endlich auch mit diesem schreck gemälde
das er angeblich eine diskriminierung
vorherrschen würde denn wenn das so wäre
frau kollegin wenn das so wäre dann
frage ist jedoch wer ist denn daran
schuld bildung ist immer noch
ländersache wer regiert denn da nicht
die afd die cdu hat ja leider in vielen
in vielen bundesländern hat die cdu
leider auch das bildungsressort
aufgegeben und den linken grünen roten
überlassen also sie sind es doch selbst
die diese angeblich so schrecklichen
zustände in den letzten jahrzehnten
geschaffen haben also hören sie auf sie
hier mit krokodilstränen zu verklagen
meine damen und herren wir haben diesen
satz x-fach gehört auch jetzt wieder
bildung ist unser wichtigster rohstoff
und das ist ja auch richtig bis auf die
ach so böse kohle hat ja deutschland
kaum rohstoffe die ursache für unseren
wirtschaftlichen erfolg liegt
ausschließlich in der intelligenz
schöpferkraft und den fleiß seiner
bewohner ein land wie unseres tut also
recht daran und da sind wir wieder
zusammen in bildung und forschung zu
investieren als hinge unser leben davon
ab und das tut es auch meine damen und
herren aber hier kommen wir zu einem
punkt wo wir uns wieder unterscheiden
wenn wir hier heute über das bafög reden
dann müssen wir glaube ich einst mal
klären sie verwechseln zumindest einige
der redner jetzt schon verwechseln auch
frau ministerin muss ich ihnen an ihrem
geburtstag auch sagen sie verwechseln
teilweise bafög mit bildung mehr bafög
heißt nicht automatisch dass dieses land
gebildet würde erfüllt meine damen und
herren vielleicht schlagen sie es
einfach mal nach wo steht das eigentlich
drin regelung zum waffe das ist teil der
sozialgesetzgebung das bafög ist eine
sozialleistung nichts anderes mehr und
dann kann man sich natürlich fragen
wer freut sich denn wenn die zahl der
bezieher eine sozialleistung hört wer
freut sich denn wenn mehr menschen vom
staat abhängig werden das sind doch die
linken parteien die sich dann freuen wir
freuen uns das sicherlich nicht meine
damen und herren
deshalb deshalb darf deshalb darf die
ausweitung des bafögs meine damen und
herren auch kein selbstzweck sein und
vielleicht erfüllt sich der wunsch auch
durch die nun eintretenden verarmung
weiter schichten der bevölkerung sie
haben uns ja in der ukraine faktisch zur
kriegspartei gemacht zumindest in
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht das bringt
enorme folgekosten mit sich die
verarmung großer teile der bevölkerung
wird zunehmen und damit natürlich auch
die zahl der bafög berechtigt aber ob
das dann ein grund zum jubeln ist weiß
ich nicht meine damen und herren in
anbetracht in anbetracht dieser dieser
situation mit der inflation die übrigens
auch nicht vom himmel fällt sondern
letztlich ja auch mit der politik der
ezb und so weiter zusammenhängt wie
haben lange davor gewarnt in dieser
situation da ist hier vorliegende
entwurf tatsächlich doch nur ein tropfen
auf den heißen stein wir haben schon
längst in der letzten legislatur
deutlich mehr gefordert sie wollen eine
erhöhung des regelbedarfs und monatlich
22 euro das gleicht inzwischen nicht
einmal mehr die inflation aus das ist
deutlich zu wenig meine damen und herren
für die die es wirklich brauchen
eine sache wundert mich allerdings jetzt
schon herr brandenburg sind wir
aufgestiegen zum parlamentarischen
staatssekretär
herzlichen glückwunsch noch einmal
nachträglich ich erinnere mich noch gut
an ihren antrag in der letzten
legislatur wo sie im einklang mit grünen
mit spd für das elternunabhängige
komplett und elternunabhängiges bafög
beworben haben also das bafög möglichst
für alle wenn wir uns jetzt diesen
gesetzentwurf anschauen meine damen und
herren das davon recht wenig geblieben
und das hat die kolleginnen staffel von
der cdu schon ganz richtig gesagt sie
haben gebrüllt werden löwe landen hier
aber als bettvorleger meine damen und
herren denn eltern unabhängig ist das
was sie hier vorliegen ja überhaupt
nicht und ich frage mich dann was hat
sie denn daran gehindert wer hat sie
denn daran gehindert war das am ende
meistens die fdp hat das
bildungsministerium waren es was die spd
waren es die grünen kann ich mir gar
nicht vorstellen oder war es der eigene
finanzminister der hier
vernünftigerweise sein veto eingelegt
hat und letztlich dem folgt was andere
auch schon in der letzten legislatur
kritisiert haben meine damen und herren
ihr waffe gesetzesvorschlag der bleibt
nach wie vor ein bürokratisches monster
und dann muss ich sie schon fragen wie
sie das denn alles bewerkstelligen
wollen wenn jetzt die zahl der anträge
steigt denn mit dem antrag ist ja nicht
getan auch mit dem digitalen abschicken
des antrags das ist auch noch damit ist
es auch noch nicht getan denn auf der
anderen seite müssen ja
beamte sitzen die diese anträge
bearbeiten und dann schauen wir doch mal
nach nordrhein westfalen wie das genau
aussieht ihre kollegin stellt dort von
der fdp stellt dort ja auch das
bildungsministerium
und unlängst konnten wir der presse
entnehmen die bearbeitungsdauer für
bafög anträge von erziehern angehenden
erzieherinnen und erziehern beträgt im
durchschnitt
128 tage im durchschnitt also mehrere
monate hängen hier die angehenden
erzieher luft nicht weil sie nicht
berechtigt werden weil sie gar nicht
erfahren ob sie berechtigt sind oder
nicht und was schlägt da ihre kollegin
aufbau ist das von der fdp vor na ja
dann sollten doch die angehende erzieher
einfach hartz 4 beantragen
meine damen und herren das ist zynisch
das ist die arroganz der macht das ist
muss ich an der stelle leider sagen
typisch fdp und ich bekomme ich hoffe
dass sie am wochenende dafür auch die
quittung bekommen
abschließend noch ein wort zum antrag
der linken der er auch heute hier mit
diskutiert wird sie gehen ja noch einen
schritt weiter jetzt bei der
altersgrenze der gesetzesvorschlag hier
sagt er nur bis 45 soll man noch ein
studium anfangen können die linken
plädieren dafür die altersgrenze
komplett abzuschaffen meine damen und
herren das wäre ein wunderbares leben
das ideale leben für alle linken und
grünen ewig studieren ewig sich
durchhangeln und im idealfall wechselt
man direkt dann vom studium in die rente
weil damen und herren ich frage mich
dann nur wer soll in diesem land dann
noch arbeiten und diesen ganzen laden am
laufen halt nicht angehen
dass freue mich für die afg fraktion in
der debatte zur novelle des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
und die nächste rednerin und jetzt laura
kraft aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen sie ist obfrau im ausschuss für
bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung
seit mehr als 50 jahren ist bafög das
wichtigste instrument um ein
bildungsaufstieg zu ermöglichen seit
mehr als 50 jahren eröffnet bafög
chancen und verändert beruflicher
lebensweg
buffett macht vieles möglich aber es
erreicht leider immer noch nicht alle
die es eigentlich dringend brauchen und
deshalb haben wir im koalitionsvertrag
eine große reform des bafög angekündigt
und unseren worten folgenden tagen und
mehreren schritten wird das bafög jetzt
zukunftsfest gemacht
hunderte der studierenden erhält bafög
leistungen und da haben sie von der
union auch eine erheblichen anteil dran
denn sie haben das bafög mit
runtergewirtschaftet denn dieser zehnte
der studierenden das entspricht absolut
nicht der hohen zahl derer die dringend
auf die finanzielle unterstützung
angewiesen sind und
bildungsgerechtigkeit die darf nicht zu
eng berechnet werden der denn derjenige
der in bildung investiert der investiert
in die zukunft
und
es ist längst überfällig dass zum
beispiel die freibetragsgrenze deutlich
angehoben werden gleich um 20 prozent
und die freibeträge und das betrifft
insbesondere das einkommen der eltern
die sind oft der hauptgrund wieso bafög
anträge abgelehnt werden und wer von den
studierenden zu viel nebenher arbeiten
muss der kommt im studium nicht mehr
hinterher und das ist das resultat
verlängerung des studiums verlängerung
der finanziellen unsicherheit und diese
probleme die haben studierende nicht die
aus einem wohlhabenden elternhaus kommen
und genau um diese diskrepanz zu
beseitigen darum wurde bafög doch
ursprünglich geschaffen
und die bisherigen bafög sätze die sind
noch nicht einmal so hoch wie der hartz4
aber das existenzminimum das muss doch
für alle menschen das gleiche bedeuten
also auch für studierende und
auszubildende
und das gleich hingegen endlich an
astronomische mietpreise einbrüche auf
dem arbeitsmarkt steigende
lebensmittelpreise
gerade jetzt zeigt sich doch auch wie
wichtig es ist den bedarfssatz immer
wieder an die tatsächlichen bedürfnisse
der studierenden
anzupassen und es hat erhöhen wir auch
die bedarfssätze um fünf prozent oder
eben auch die wohn pauschale um 10 und
wir werden auch in zukunft die führung
kontinuierlich anpassen
und uns grüne war besonders wichtig auch
die anhebung der altersgrenze
lebenshilfen sie mit vielfältiger
geworden darauf müssen wir reagieren
und wer eben beruflich neue wege
einschlagen muss der braucht die
möglichkeit für eine neue qualifizierung
und das ohne sich dafür verschulden zu
müssen
ein wichtiger schritt ist auch der
wegfall der schriftformerfordernis denn
dann hin gehen wir dann auch ein damit
gehen wir dann auch einen wichtigen
schritt in richtung digitalisierung in
der verwaltung in der antragstellung und
auch wenn das jetzt nicht zu diesen
gesetzesentwurf gehört so möchte ich
trotzdem noch betonen dass ich sehr froh
bin dass wir das bafög auch für
geflüchtete studierende aus der ukraine
öffnen werden und wir sie unkompliziert
unterstützen dass sie ihre ausbildung
fortführen können das kann nicht an
dieser stelle
und uns ist klar der größte teil der
bafög-reform de liegt noch vor uns aber
mit dieser gesetzesänderung schaffen wir
den ersten etappensieg und erreichen
dass noch zum nächsten semester ganz
konkret noch mehr junge menschen
unmittelbar vom bafög profitieren können
und darüber freue ich mich vielen dank
laura kraft für die fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen und ihr wird jetzt folgen als
nächste rednerin nicole gohlke aus der
linksfraktion und in dieser
linksfraktion ist nicole gohlke
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und liebe studierende auf der
besuchertribüne endlich kommt mal
schwung in die bafög tipp hatte die
reformen die mit der 27 novelle jetzt
endlich angegangen wäre sind überfällig
und man muss es wirklich noch mal sagen
es war ein schweres schweres versagen
der letzten bundesregierungen das war
für mich schon viel früher angepackt
haben angepackt zu haben dieses
versorgen dass das versäumnis hat
zehntausenden jungen menschen in den
letzten jahren zeit geld nerven und
gesundheit gekostet und viele viele hat
es sogar das studium oder den abschluss
gekostet ein unfassbarer umgang mit
begabungen perspektiven und
lebensträumen das muss hier einfach noch
mal ausgesprochen werden nun kommen also
endlich die erhöhung der altersgrenze
von 30 auf 45 jahre die erhöhung der
elternfreibeträge die erhöhungen bei der
wohn-pauschale und bei den bedarfssätzen
frau ministerin ganz klar es ist gut
dass sie hier endlich tätig werden
dieses engagement unterstützen wir voll
und ganz nun liegt die tücke aber
natürlich wie immer im detail denn
leider wird auch die jetzige reform an
vielen stellen gar nicht so viel
verändern wie jetzt hier vielleicht
versprochen wird die bedarfssätze werden
auch weiterhin den realen bedarf nicht
decken das ist die situation die
erhöhung der bedarfssätze um fünf
prozent wird durch die inflationsrate
von derzeit mehr als sieben prozent
komplett aufgefressen und das heißt dann
natürlich im klartext dass auch das neue
bafög unterhalb der armutsgrenze liegen
wird und unter hartz iv niveau liegen
wird und das von ministerin das können
sie nicht als großen wurf und
bildungspolitischen aufbruch verkaufen
sondern an diesem punkt an diesem punkt
rein sie sich dann schlicht ein in die
reihe derer die eben die axt ans bafög
angelegt haben das ist die wahrheit und
ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht welche studien
in welchen städten und welche mietpreise
sie so vor augen haben mit den realen
mietpreisen haben ihre zahlen nichts zu
tun sonst wären sie vielleicht endlich
mal auf die idee gekommen den
mietkostenzuschuss
analog wie das wohngeld regional zu
staffeln weil eben die miete in münchen
oder in stuttgart oder in berlin teurer
ist das vielleicht die in cottbus das
wäre doch mal eine gute idee warum gehen
sie da eigentlich nicht endlich ran vor
ministerin und es braucht auch endlich
die automatische anpassung der bafög
sätze an die inflationsrate steigt
diesem zustand den wir jetzt haben wo in
völlig willkürlichen abständen und
einfach je nach stimmungslage in der
jeweiligen koalition
sozusagen die sätze erhöht werden ohne
dass aber überhaupt mal systematisch
geprüft wird ob die summen die am ende
sozusagen zur verfügung stehen den
eigentlichen zweck des bafög die
eigentliche bestimmung des bafög
überhaupt erfüllen und die eigentliche
bestimmung des bafög ist lebensunterhalt
und ausbildung bedarfsgerecht zu sichern
so steht es in § 11 bdsg gesetzt das ist
der auftrag des bafög und sie müssen dem
endlich mal nachkommen
und bei aller freude bei aller freude
über die deutliche anhebung der
elternfreibeträge muss man zumindest
fragen ob dadurch tatsächlich am ende
die zahl der bafög beziehen relevant
steigen denn man muss natürlich auch
nach den gründen fragen warum
studierende die eben vielleicht auch
jetzt schon förderberechtigt sind die
förderung nicht in anspruch nehmen und
das liegt meist daran dass entweder die
fördersummen so gering sind dass sich
der aufwand gar nicht lohnt oder zweiter
grund weil die jungen menschen angst vor
verschuldung haben und damit bin ich bei
meinem letzten punkt den ich hier
ansprechen möchte wir müssen endlich
wieder zurück zum vollzuschuss der
darlehens teilen muss dringend
gestrichen werden die frage ob man sich
für die ausbildung oder ein studium
verschulden muss ist zentral beim abbau
von sozialer ungleichheit und dieses
leitmotiv abbau von sozialer
ungleichheit muss ich durch die politik
und natürlich ganz besonders durch die
bildungspolitik der staat muss
diskriminierung abbauen und darf keine
neuen hürden aufbauen diesem leitmotiv
wird die ampel regierung leider noch
nicht gerecht dass man sich dringend
ändern vielen dank fürs zuhören
nicole gohlke stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion und wie
schon mal erwähnt die linke hat einen
antrag eingebracht diese debatte mit dem
titel bafög existenz sichern und
krisenfest gestaltende entsprechen die
anmerkungen eben von nicole gohlke
nächste rednerin ist via schröder die
bildungspolitische sprecherin der fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen am ersten
september 1971 trat das bafög in kraft
unüberhörbar müssen damals die
jubelschreie der katholischen
arbeitertochter vom land gewesen sein
denn bis dahin ein studium für sie nur
ein kühner traum geld dafür wollen der
familie wieder vorhanden noch vorgesehen
und sie würde ja ohnehin heiraten das
bafög veränderte das leben dieser jungen
frau es gab ihr stift und papier an die
hand um endlich selbst autorin ihrer
bildungsbiographie zu werden die
einführung des bafög war ein echter
meilenstein für das aufstiegsversprechen
wie steht s 2022 darum ist heute alles
besser von wegen und frau staffler das
ist ihre verantwortung seit über zehn
jahren bekommen kontinuierlich immer
weniger menschen bafög obwohl die
chancenungleichheit zunimmt das spricht
bände aber es schreibt keine neuen
aufstiegs biografie wir werden jungen
menschen wieder grund zum jubeln geben
und zum jubeln für die kinder aus
familien die zu wenig haben um ihre
kinder unterstützen zu können aber zu
viel und bafög zu bekommen die sind
nicht reich sondern das bafög erreicht
sie nicht mehr und das ändern wir mit
dieser überfälligen novelle
wir schaffen die krasseste erhöhung der
freibeträge in der geschichte des bafög
eine erhöhung um 20 prozent und machen
studieren so eltern unabhängiger der
erhöhen die bedarfssätze besonders beim
wohnen um 11% übrigens frau burke das
ist mehr als inflationsausgleich und bei
sich
biographien heute nicht mehr nur mit
stift und papier schreiben schaffen wir
mit dem verzicht auf das
schriftformerfordernis endlich die
voraussetzungen für echte digitale
antragstellung ohne medienbrüche oder
die bildung und digitalisierung dafür
vier jungen menschen fdp gewählt wir
liefern
eine andere sache möchte ich noch
ansprechen denn
2022 übernehmen wir verantwortung auch
für bildungsbiografien die durch den
brutalen angriffskrieg abzureißen droht
deshalb ist es richtig und wichtig dass
wir heute nachmittag mit dem
einmalzahlung und sofort zuschlag
gesetzt das bafög auch für ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer öffnen
meine damen und herren bildung ist
bürgerrecht titelte einst reif
dahrendorf nicht weniger ist unser
anspruch und da haben lassen sie uns
diesen bildungschancen aufbruch heute
gemeinsam auf den weg bringen
rea schröder die bildungspolitische
sprecherin der
fdp-fraktion
und ihr folgt monika grütters aus der
unionsfraktion in der vorigen
legislaturperiode
staatsministerin für kultur im
kanzleramt
auch präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren der berühmte
bildungsforscher und gelehrte erasmus
von rotterdam bus der nicht um zu
studieren leben wir sondern wir
studieren um angenehm leben zu können
und dass die koalition mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf das bafög an
die steigenden lebenshaltungskosten
anpasst das ist beinahe
selbstverständlich damit studium und in
erasmus sind angenehmes leben weiter
wirklichkeit bleiben können gerade auch
für die jungen menschen ist richtig und
findet selbstverständlich die
unterstützung unserer fraktion
aber frau burke
wir alle hier tun ja unser möglichstes
und neuen bildungs ausstiege ermöglichen
was mich wundert ist dass sie dich und
so lange in bildungs auszusetzen
vergessen konnten das zurückliegende
bafög-reform zum beispiel von 2009 10
deutlich mutiger ausgefallen sind als
der kleine wurf heute hier damals haben
wir 30 prozent lohnzuschlag ermöglicht
heute sind zehn damals 13 prozent mehr
kinderbetreuung heute nur 5 ich glaube
also es gehört zur redlichkeit dazu dass
man auch die vergangenen jahre ehrlich
einpreist denn dass die koalition die
jetzige die ampelkoalition gleichzeitig
beim entlastungspaket die studierenden
promi ausgehen lässt muss ein an der
ernsthaftigkeit auch dieser übung doch
ein wenig zweifeln lassen der zweifel
wird umso größer wenn man sich vor augen
führt es ist ja hier bereits angeklungen
dass die koalition mit dem vorliegenden
gesetzentwurf nur den geringsten teil
einer im koalitionsvertrag jedenfalls
vollmundig angekündigten großen waffe
trägt worden um selbst die schwierigen
schritte eine strukturelle reform der
ausbildungsförderung werden also
vorsichtshalber auf später verschoben
und für dieses verhalten habe ich eine
sehr nette schöne erklärung lust auf der
studienberatung der freien universität
gefunden dort hieß es die der ausdruck
prokrastination bezieht sich darauf als
dringend notwendig betrachtete aufgaben
aufzuschieben und stattdessen etwas
anderes vielleicht vom geringere
priorität weniger essentielles zu machen
für diese handlung finden personen
übrigens typischerweise entschuldigung
liebe kollegin kollegen das bafög und
damit die soziale säule im
hochschulsystem unseres landes zu
stärken ist natürlich richtig es wäre
aber fatal wenn sich darin der anspruch
dieser koalition für eine kluge
bildungspolitik bereits erschöpfen würde
denn eine frage bleibt ja bisher auch
nach einem halben jahr ampelkoalition in
der bildung unbeantwortet hat die
koalition den jungen menschen an unseren
hochschulen mehr zu bieten als die reine
erhöhung der sozialleistungen fausel auf
sie haben es ja eben angemahnt
vielleicht kennen sie die antwort was
tut die ampel für die unzähligen bull
bildungshungrigen jungen menschen an
unseren hochschulen die leistungsstark
und leistungsbereit sind für jene also
die im besten sinne erasmus leistungs
ethos folgen wollen ich kenne jedenfalls
viele studierende die beides erwarten
und möchten sozial abgesichert sein und
ihren ehrgeiz unter beweis stellen zu
den bisherigen aufgaben und zu den
großen aufgaben unseres bildungs und
wissenschaftssystem gehört es jedenfalls
nicht nur gleich
gerechtigkeit chancengerechtigkeit
herzustellen sondern das gewinnt seine
legitimation gerade auch durch die
ausdrückliche förderung von talent
begabung und leistungsbereitschaft auch
hier vermissen wir entschlossen impulse
deshalb muss sich diese position sowohl
im hinblick auf eine vollständige
bafög-reform als auch auf den
begabtenförderung
erasmus kritische fragen gefallen lassen
wie viele male schaut der wille noch
durchs fenster die tat durch store geht
vielen dank
monika grütters war das hier in der
debatte zur änderung des bafög gesetzes
und auf sie folgt oliver kaczmarek wie
die spd sprecher für bildung und
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja das
bafög ist teil des ausstiegs
versprechens auch für viele von uns
gewesen auch für mich selbst das problem
ist aber dass es heute für viele
studierende das für viele auszubildende
nicht mehr erfahrbar ist in der gelebten
realität und deswegen müssen wir erst
wieder zum teil des aufstiegs
versprechendes machen und dazu wird
heute der erste schritt getan und er ist
richtig und wichtig
wir wissen zu viele studierende und
auszubildende haben zu wenig geld wir
wissen dass aus den erhebungen die wir
im rahmen der überbrückungshilfe für
studierende in der pandemie gemacht
haben viele anträge konnten nicht
bewilligt werden nicht als menschen
nicht arm waren sondern weil sie schon
vor der pandemie armband und wenn man
sich das vor augen führt dann gibt es
doch nur eine schlussfolgerung die man
daraus ziehen kann wir müssen das bafög
für mehr menschen ermöglichen denn das
bafög unterstützt sie bei ihrer
ausbildung und deshalb ist unser ziel
mit diesem gesetz nicht nur mehr bafög
sondern vor allen dingen mehr waffen für
viel mehr menschen die an den
hochschulen in der ausbildung sind
und mehr bafög das heißt für uns der
höchstsatz steigt jetzt um mehr als
sieben prozent auf 931 euro das ist noch
nicht das ende von allen bemühungen in
dieser wahlperiode
aber das ist auch nicht nichts und vor
allen dingen die fixierung auf die
bedarfssätze für dann in die irre wenn
ich gleichzeitig die voraussetzungen
dafür geschaffen werden dass neben auch
die menschen diese bedarfssätze in
anspruch nehmen können und deswegen
heißt für uns mehr menschen im bafög vor
allen dingen und das ist der kern dieses
gesetzes ein wesentlicher kern natürlich
gibt es noch viele andere bestandteile
mehr menschen den walfang das heißt für
uns freibeträge um 20 prozent drauf das
ist ein mutiger schritt damit dass bei
eben besser auch gegen armut schützen
kann damit es eben mehr menschen den
anspruch nehmen
ich muss an dieser stelle sagen ja das
hätten wir schon längst tun können das
hätten wir vielleicht auch schon längst
tun müssen und ich wundere mich ein
bisschen bei aller wertschätzung frau
-staffel verräters über ihre räder aus
der union denn jeder hier im saal weiß
dass wir die gelegenheit schon in der
letzten wahlperiode gehabt hätten aber
sie haben sehenden auges bei sinkenden
geförderten zahlen dazu beigetragen dass
die freibetrags anpassungen die wir als
spd der koalition mehrfach angeboten
haben nicht angegangen worden sind
angegangen worden ist sie haben
verhindert dass sie in der letzten
wahlperiode schon die trendwende mit
mutigen schritten eingeleitet haben weil
sie ja das bafög nicht mehr angepasst
haben angefasst haben und deswegen sind
ihre reden die entweder vergesslich oder
schlecht begonnen
wir morgen dass das wie beim bafög
endlich wieder die kurve kriegen dass
die bafög zahlen nach oben geben darauf
können sich die studierenden und
auszubildenden verlassen davon werden
wir das gesetz dann gegebenenfalls wenn
wir sehen wir müssten nachjustieren auch
noch mal in die hand nehmen und nicht so
wie in der letzten wahlperiode
einstellen und nicht mehr in die hand
nehmen wir wollen dass das am ende auch
transparent geschickt deswegen wird
übrigens auch kein bericht verschoben
oder sowas das ist ja auch hier schon
gegeben hat meine damen und herren
studieren und azubis auszubildende haben
in der pandemie viel solidarität gezeigt
einen beitrag geleistet dazu dass wir
die pandemie überwunden haben oder
vielleicht überwunden überwinden werden
aber ihre ansprüche haben sich oft nicht
wiedergefunden und deswegen ist es jetzt
umso wichtiger angesichts steigender
energiepreise angesichts steigender
lebenshaltungskosten dass wir die lage
und die belange von studierenden und
auszubildenden nicht nur sehen sondern
sich auch konkret unterstützt und will
an dieser stelle
will an dieser stelle nochmal sagen dass
wir dazu ein umfangreiches paket zur
entlassung von studierenden
auszubildenden auf den weg gebracht habe
ich will das noch mal kurz sagen heute
der erste schritt zum bafög erhöhung und
ausweitung auf viel mehr menschen
zweitens studierenden auszubildenden die
bafög bekommen oder
berufsausbildungsbeihilfe bekommen
teilweise auf den aufstiegs bafög
bekommen einen heizkostenzuschuss von
230 euro das haben wir hier schon
beschlossen drittens bringt in dieser
woche als neun euro ticket auf den weg
das wird dazu führen dass die
studierenden die eingeschrieben sind und
ein semesterticket haben bei dem
nächsten semester beitrag eine deutliche
reduktion ihrer mobilitätskosten
erfahren werden
das geht richtig was von günterstal
gesagt hat dass studierende nicht im
entlastungspaket sind denn auch mini
jobber werden die energiepreis pauschale
von 300 euro erhalten das heißt auch
studierende mit minijob wir wissen dass
fast drei viertel aller studierenden
leben tätigkeiten nachgehen ich behaupte
nicht dass damit alles gelöst ist aber
ich kann sehr selbstbewusst sagen das
sind echte und wirksame entlastung für
auszubildende und studierende
wir haben als koalition die junge
generation im blick
ein letzter satz möchte die geflüchteten
aus der ukraine ins bafög aufnehmen ich
war erschüttert als sie dem ausschuss
festgestellt habe dass die union diesen
schritt nicht mitgehen will ich glaube
bei der ganzen wortgewaltig kite diese
bei dieser frage ansonsten an den tag
legen geben sich einen ruck ukrainische
studierende haben das recht
da sie das land verlassen mussten hier
ihre ausbildung fortzusetzen und auch
bafög dafür zu erhalten indem sich
eindruck das ist eine wichtige maßnahme
da gibt es überhaupt keinen grund
dagegen zu sein
oliver kaczmarek war das und sie sehen
das schon wir erwarten in kürze ein
presse statement von
bundesminister harbeck zusammen mit dem
präsidenten der bundesnetzagentur klaus
müller die sich zu den russischen
gegenmaßnahmen äußern wollen zu den
deutschen entscheidungen zu gazprom
germania das
und viertel vor also in wenigen minuten
so lange bleiben wir aber natürlich in
der debatte nina star spricht jetzt für
bündnis 90/die grünen
konkret 100 kinder kommen auf die welt
gehen in die kita gehen zur grundschule
alle haben die gleichen chancen weil sie
haben ja den gleichen unterricht die
gleichen lehrkräfte den gleichen
arbeitsblätter trotzdem am ende der
grundschulzeit haben kinder aus
akademikerhaushalten knapp dreimal so
häufig die gymnasiale empfehlung wie
kinder aus nicht akademiker haushalten
chancengleichheit offensichtlich nicht
und das setzt sich fort die kollegin
seite hat das angedeutet von diesen 100
kinder rang 74 wenn sie aus
akademikerhaushalten vom ein studium an
sich aus nicht akademiker haushalten und
promotion machen dann aus den akademiker
haushalten zehn kinder und aus dem nicht
akademiker haushalten eins von hundert
ein kind
und natürlich ist das häufig so aus
finanziellen gründen und genau das
werden wir als ampelkoalition jetzt
ändern
[Applaus]
für uns bedeutet chancengerechtigkeit
die chancengleichheit eben auch
chancengerechtigkeit und das heißt nicht
jedem einfach dasselbe fortzusetzen und
zu sagen bitte schön was gut draus
machst das ist deine verantwortung
natürlich ist klar jeder muss für seinen
eigenen erfolg auch selber arbeiten aber
es bedeutet eben auch dass alle wirklich
die gleichen zugänge haben müssen und da
wo das elternhaus diese zugänge nicht
bieten kann da sind wir als staat in der
pflicht zu unterstützen
und deswegen deswegen liegt mir
persönlich auch das startchancen
programm so sehr am herzen weil es im
schulischen bereich eben genau dieses
versprechen von chancengleichheit ein
stück weiter werben lässt und am ende
der schulzeit da ist eben diese
bafög-reform ein meilenstein für
chancengerechtigkeit und ich bin
deswegen der ministerin sehr sehr
dankbar dass sie wie das
gesetzesvorhaben mit so viel nachdruck
und so viel schnelligkeit vorangetrieben
habe dass es deshalb jetzt schon zum
wintersemester wirksam werden kann
mit dieser reform öffnen wir das bafög
zu viel mehr menschen die anhebung der
altersgrenze die anhebung der
freibeträge das sorgt dafür dass nach
einem jahrelangen rückgang der zahlen
endlich wieder mehr menschen bafög
beziehen können und da wundere wundere
ich mich schon frau staffler dass sie
hier erzählen wie viel die cdu getan hat
in den letzten jahren wenn jetzt noch 11
prozent der studios und ab sowie spa iv
beziehen das heißt 89 der menschen eben
nicht und das ändern wir insbesondere
mit der höchsten anhebung der
freibeträge nämlich um 20 prozent das
ändern wir jetzt wir holen das auch was
die cdu jahrelang versäumt hat und
mit mit der digitalisierung der antrag
stellen bauen wir bauen wir natürlich
auch weitere hürden ab und sorgen so
dafür dass der zugang zum bafög
einfacher wird und damit eben auch der
zugang zum studium einfacher wird ich
freue mich das ist heute auch schon
mehrmals gesagt worden ganz besonders
dass wir das bafög jetzt auch für die
jungen menschen aus der ukraine öffnen
so geben wir menschen schnell wieder
eine perspektive und so gelingt
integration
ich möchte aber an dieser stelle eine
persönliche bemerkung machen die art und
weise dieser pragmatische umgang die
offenen arme die wir den menschen aus
der ukraine gezeigt haben das wünsche
ich mir für die zukunft für alle
befürchteten
aber es geht natürlich nicht es geht
nicht nur um einfacheren zugang sondern
auch darum dass alle studierenden die
sicherheit haben ganz unabhängig vom
elternhaus egal ob akademiker elternhaus
oder eben auch nicht für das studium
finanziell abgesichert zu sein dafür
muss man vom bafög auf leben können mit
der deutlichen anhebung der bedarfssätze
des kinderbetreuungszuschlag und des
wohn zuschlags sorgen wir dafür dass
junge menschen von dem geld das ihnen
zur verfügung steht auch leben können es
wurde häufig gesagt diese bafög reform
ist der erste schritt wir werden die
förderungsdauer verlängern wir werden
den fachrichtungswechsel erleichtern die
bedarfssätze weiter anpassen und mit der
studienstadt hilfe junger menschen
finanziell schwachen familien den ersten
schritt in die ausbildung erleichtern
wir werden die nothilfe ein finden und
damit auch in triesen die menschen
besser absichern und das ist mein
letzter satz frau präsidentin bin mir
sicher mit dieser reform und den
folgenden schritten tragen wir als
ampelkoalition maßgeblich zum erfolg für
junge menschen und wir gehen rüber zur
bundesminister robert habeck